, the meltdowns that we started seeing last
night and overnight into this morning as
Pennsylvania and Georgia flipped
to Joe Biden are just fantastic.
I want to start with Sean Hannity last
night as the numbers were trending
against Donald Trump in Pennsylvania. Here
is Sean Hannity saying, hey, you know what,
we probably need to just redo the entire election
in Pennsylvania just to do the entire thing. We
need a do over because we're not getting the
results that we want. You have to see this.
Does that invalidate the process, considering
they're violating the law? And what is the
remedy? The only remedy I would see that point
is they did it and they violated the law.
Nobody can testify to the legitimacy of what their
counting was. Oh, what a do over in that state,
by the way, something that has never
been done in a presidential election.
By the way, I just got this breaking.
The only remedy that Sean Hannity sees
because of nonexistent voter fraud is
throw out the results from Pennsylvania
and redo the entire election. That's enough out
of Sean, isn't it? Is this is not best. Two out
of three, Pennsylvania voted and as the votes
were counted, more people voted for Joe Biden.
That's it. And it's very simple. And you know
that this is all on them because we knew that
the mail in vote was going to be heavily Biden
vote. The rules they established are you don't
start counting the mail in votes in Pennsylvania
until the polls close. So, of course, you're going
to get the in-person vote first and then the mail
and votes are going to be counted. We all knew
that this was going to happen. And Hannity ends
up sounding sort of like the kid during kickball.
Hey, you know, OK, that fine. It looked like a
foul ball, but it specifically hit a certain tree.
And when the acorn fell out of the tree, it's
actually a home run, even though it's in foul
territory. Get out of here, dude. They violated
the law. What law? They don't even understand
their own conspiracy theories. Donald Trump and
Don Jr. certainly don't. And this is going to
continue for a long time. As we've been filming
today's show, it increasingly seems like the move
among Fox News and others is going to be simply to
refuse to say that Donald Trump has actually lost.
And this is going to be bolstered by Donald Trump
not conceding from the reports we're getting now.
Fox News may not even refer to Joe Biden
as the president elect. This is going to
go for a while by every indication. And they are
going when when Trump said he's going to use the
courts and maybe Amy CONI Beareth or the Supreme
Court or whoever will decide he wasn't kidding.
He was very serious about that. No, none of
this stuff, you know, all the all the last two
weeks of folks writing to me saying, David, these
things are probably exaggerations. No, no, no, no,
no. It's all happening exactly as they will they
promised. And it's going to continue for some time